covet is completely out of control in
lee county florida cases have been
spiking to what are easily the pandemic
high numbers it's total chaos it's
pandemonium it's bedlam school board
meetings across the country are going to
start needing security or for the ones
that already have security they're going
to start needing more security as the
case may be
this has to stop or it has to be stopped
somehow right even if you think that as
a parent you're doing something good for
your kid by acting out against masks
don't you think it's even bad for the
kid to know that their mom or dad
is losing their mind and protesting and
humiliating themselves on tv or in front
of the community like however annoying
you think wearing the mask is for your
kid and for most kids it doesn't seem
very annoying quite frankly uh isn't
that not as bad
as a kid being like oh no mom is doing
it again mom's in a fight at the school
board meeting
dad is talking about dad's wearing a
hazmat suit and talking about hitler